-What a special night it is.
Our entire audience
is made up of people
Gordon Sondland implicated
in the Ukraine scandal.
Isn't that beautiful?
[ Cheers and applause ]
A special night.
That's right --
today was day four
of the impeachment hearings.
I don't want to say things
are bad for Trump,
but right now,
not even baby Yoda
could cheer that guy up.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it was a wild day
in Washington.
Today, we heard testimony
from Ambassador Gordon Sondland,
who directly implicated Trum
in the Ukraine scandal.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
You could tell
it was bad for Trump,
because he did something
he never does.
He turned off the TV.
[ Laughter ]
And that's
when you know it's bad.
Yep, Ambassador Sondland
basically implicated Trump
Rudy Giuliani,
and most of his cabinet.
At this point, Trump grabbed
his chest and said,
"I think I'm ready
for phase two of my physical."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously,
Sondland named all of them
He was basically
the Oprah of witnesses.
Like, "You're going to jail!
You're going to jail!
You're going to jail!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you didn't see
Sondland flip on Trump today
basically, it looked like this
♪♪♪♪
-Yeah, it was --
Can we --
[ Laughter ]
Can we see a photo
of Gordon Sondland?
There he is, yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
Some of you may recognize hi
from his famous line
in "The Princess Bride"
when he said, "Inconceivable!"
[ Laughter ]
The bombshell
from today's hearing happene
when Ambassador Sondland
clearly stated,
"There was a quid pro quo.
-Was there a quid pro quo
with regard
to the requested
White House call
and the White House meeting?
The answer is yes.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-The quid pro quo
is really bad news for Trump
mostly because now
he has to learn Latin words.
[ Laughter ]
"I barely know English.
Expecto patronum."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's not Latin.
That's not --
Don't tell him, don't tell him
Right after that,
Mike Pence was on the phone,
like, "Can you send someon
to move all my stuff
into the Oval Office?
Thank you."
But later in the hearing,
Sondland was questioned
about Mike Pence's
role in all of this.
-And you mentioned
that you also had a conversation
with Vice President Pence.
What did you say
to the Vice President?
-I said, "It appears that
everything is stalled
until this statement gets made."
And the Vice President
nodded like,
you know, he heard what I said
-Then Pence
was back on the phone, like,
"Um, on second thought, you ca
cancel that last request."
[ Laughter ]
All day long,
people were calling
Sondland's testimony explosive
Explosive.
Yeah.
Haven't heard the word
"explosive" so much
since Chipotle
started selling queso.
[ Laughter ]
This is going viral.
After Sondland noted many time
in his opening statements
there was a quid pro quo,
there was a brief recess.
And you could see
the disappointment
in Devin Nunes' face.
Take a look at this.
-Why don't we take
a 5- or 10-minute break?
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-The last time Nunes
made that face
was when Chili's told him it was
gonna be a 40-minute wait
and then handed him
a table buzzer.
He's like...
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, after Sondland
dropped a bomb on Trump,
this photo of him went --
testifying went viral.
Take a look.
[ Laughter ]
I can tell exactly
what he's thinking there.
Swish swish, bish.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Dang.
-Overall, it was a brutal da
for the President.
On NBC, Chuck Todd said th
Democrats were doing a great job
building their case
brick by brick.
So it sounds like the Democrat
are gonna get their wall
before Trump.
[ Laughter, groans ]
Now, I'm not saying Trump
is in trouble,
but Vladimir Putin
spent the day thinking,
"We better
find new candidate for 2020.
[ Laughter ]
"Start making friends
with Ramona from 'Housewives.'
[ Laughter ]
Well, millions of people
have watched
the Trump impeachment hearings
but there are reports
that Americans
are starting to tune out.
Some people say
they just don't understand
who any of the main players are,
so we thought we'd help you ou
by telling you who they are,
along with some trivia
about them.
It's time for "Tonight Sho
Impeachment Trivia."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪♪ It's the Tonight Show
♪♪ Impeachment Trivia ♪♪
♪♪ Yeah ♪♪
-First up is Jim Jordan.
He's the Republican on
the Intelligence committee
Some trivia about him is,
he works out by punching holes
in the drywall of his office
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next is Adam Schiff.
He's the chair of the Hous
Intelligence Committee.
Some trivia about him is,
he's legally
his own bobblehead.
Oh, that --
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next is Devin Nunes.
He's a Republican representative
from California.
Some fun trivia about him is
he took his chair to prom.
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next is Marie Yovanovitch.
She's a former
U.S. ambassador to Ukraine
Some trivia about her is,
her Xbox Live username is
skullcrushervapelord82.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'd definitely play
"Call of Duty" with her.
She's solid.
Yeah.
Next is Jennifer Williams.
She's a veteran
Foreign Service officer.
Some trivia about her is, sh
gone-girled her last husband
-Wow.
[ Laughter, groans ]
-"No, Officer,
I haven't seen him in weeks.
I don't know where he could be."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
we have George Kent.
He's a deputy assistant
Secretary of State
for European
and Eurasian affairs,
but you guys already knew that
[ Laughter ]
Some trivia about him is,
if you squeeze his tummy,
something fun happens.
[ Squishing noises ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you go, guys.
There's your
"Impeachment Trivia."
I hope that helps.
Trump actually watched
the rest of the hearings
while flying on Air Force One.
I'm not saying Trump is worried,
but at one point
during the flight, he opened
the door to get some air.
[ Laughter ]
-"Wall."
-Meanwhile, impeachment hearings
were happening,
Trump toured Apple's
manufacturing facility
in Texas with Apple CEO
Tim Cook.
Now, previously, Trump calle
Apple CEO Tim Cook "Tim Apple.
[ Laughter ]
But to his credit, Trump didn'
make the same mistake this time.
He called him "Tim Computer.
[ Laughter ]
"Tim Computer,
very nice to see you."
[ Laughter ]
I'm not sure Trump's mind
was in the right place
at the Apple facility.
At one point, he started
swallowing a bunch of pill
until someone said,
"Sir, those are Airpods."
[ Laughter ]
Well, earlier tonight was the --
[ Laughter continues ]
"I wonder why they're so long.
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh, those are gonna hurt."
-"I thought it was
a deluxe Tylenol.
I have no idea."
[ Laughter ]
Earlier tonight
was the fifth Democratic debate.
Going into it, Biden was i
first and Warren was in second
But after what happened today,
the new Democratic favorit
is Gordon Sondland.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Tonight's debate was hosted b
MSNBC and "The Washington Post."
I guess they tried to get th
two things Trump hates the most,
but Eric and Don Jr.
were busy.
[ Laughter, groans ]
Well, the Grammy nominations
were announced today,
and I saw that Lizzo led
everyone with eight nominations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Lizzo.
Which feels right --
Which feels right,
since "Truth Hurts"
definitely seems to be
the theme of the day.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is cool --
Michelle Obama was nominated
for a Grammy
for Best Spoken Word.
[ Cheers and applause ]
While Worst Spoken Word
once again went to this guy.
-You have never stopped workin
to improve this country
and your "derrer" government
[ Laughter ]
-What -- What was that?
-He just --
He just bailed on it.
-Yeah.
"Undrrla..."
-He was trying to say "deserve."
He was like, "I don't care
I don't care anymore."
Can we play that again?
Dave, do we have that again?
-...country and your
"derrer" government.
[ Laughter ]
-This is exciting.
I saw that "Jeopardy!" will host
a "Greatest of All Time"
tournament in January.
But to be fair,
they're also hosting
a Worst of All Time tournament
We actually got a sneak peek a
it, and it lives up to the name.
Take a look.
-He quickly became
the Democratic front-runne
after announcing his third bid
for president April 25, 2019
Kevin.
-Who's Kevin Hart?
-No.
-This series is a spin-off
of "The Big Bang Theory"
and also a prequel to it.
Shannon.
-What is "White Men Can't Jump"?
-No.
In "A Beautiful Bay
in the Neighborhood,"
beloved children's TV show host,
Mister Rogers
is played by this beloved actor?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, sorry.
And his name is Mickey Spillane.
-There you go?
[ Laughter and applause ]
What?
What are you talking about
Finally, there's a new
male birth control
about to go on the market,
but it involves men
getting an injection
into their groin.
Meanwhile, women are like,
"Aww. Try childbirth."
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a great show!